[Musik]
anna rosenwasser ist glücklich es ist
der 26
september die schweiz hat gerade klar
mit über 64 prozent ja gesagt zur ehe
für alle an der abstimmungs freiheit und
liest die quere community den erfolg ein
erfolg der vielen gehört und auch ein
bisschen her anna rosenwasser 31
aktivistin feministin influenza
seg und riesige formate spanier sind
wichtig und die gleichberechtigung
verlieren und das ist nicht nur
politisch dass ich habe
das klare abstimmungsergebnis steht für
eine neue gesellschaftliche akzeptanz
von krones und dafür setzt anna
rosenwasser sich ein sie kämpft gegen
homophobie sexismus und diskriminierung
und sie tut dies laut fordernd
selbstbewusst
nette formulierung sei es mehr krampf
lesbe sagt macht
politik ich mich aber es gibt in altburg
bundespolitisch ist in den letzten
jahren war anna rosenwasser als
geschäftsführerin der lesbenorganisation
schweiz eines der wichtigsten gesichter
der lgbt szene
location auch in den sozialen medien
ihre instagram post sind politisch
persönlich immer ein bisschen rosa aber
auch provokant und hass ich
was steckt hinter diesem neuen
selbstbewusstsein
[Musik]
september 2020 ein jahr zuvor anna
bereitet sich auf einer party vor sie
will auffallen das queer sein
zelebrieren
das outfit wird es
geht am mega viel queens wo
sagen hör bitte mit ab 20 er mache das
quasi ein schlachtruf eintracht lose
normal und 18 14 und
verstoß bedürfnis noch einmal mehr
gefischt aber ich bin ja mit normalität
verstanden was ist das wäre normal ich
habe mir das gefühl gibt es jetzt nicht
mehr voll schlaf der normalität wurde
ich nicht bewiesen sagte zurück
heute findet das jugend festival lila
statt wo sich die community alljährlich
trifft eine community die sich in den
letzten jahren regelrecht ins
bewusstsein der öffentlichkeit und
mitten in die jugendkultur gespült hat
hier feiert sie sich mit all ihren
buchstaben l für lesbische 4g also
schwul bisexuell t für transco für
queere der überbegriff für alle deren
geschlechtliche identität von der norm
abweicht
[Musik]
anna rosenwasser führt heute durch das
programm nervös sprach erstaunlich eine
böse sache weil es halt das publikum ist
und ich weiß sie haben nicht gerne könnt
auch das nicht so gut mache der vorne
und hinten nicht trotzdem gern durch
eine lied kriegt sie die gut ich gern
haben und das ist so ein schönes gefühl
vom schönste eigentlich
libysche switches denn die was
willkommen seite doch vom lila festival
20.20 uhr
ort wiener festival sind zwar da sagen
wir
sind nur da und glücklich obwohl nie und
so sehen wir sind sondern wir sind
glücklich wenn wir also sind wir sind
antwort
ich stolz wer ist stolz
einer rosenwasser setzt sich in szene
sie wird gefeiert und genießt es und der
selbstinszenierung
ja er ist ein teil selbst inszenieren
kann man schwer
positionieren dann wäre wohl andere
formen von politischer arbeit mache es
gibt ja megabit wo politisch für das
klima schafft wird wie und wo das
informel machen wo ihre visage nicht
uninteressant ist das sind sehr häufig
arbeiten wo nichts mehr
und sie war natürlich einen installer
kanals führen wo sich die kameraden
sprachen stoffen greifen
stern entlang
[Musik]
anna rosenwasser mitten in der community
eine familie die selbstbewusstsein und
zugehörigkeit gibt und in der anna auch
vorbild ist ihre popularität führt zu
einer wachsenden zahl von followern auf
instagram
[Musik]
dass sie selbst wie er ist hat anna
rosenwasser erst vor einigen jahren
entdeckt seit dreieinhalb jahren ist sie
mit florina zusammen die beiden teilen
eine gemeinsame liebe katzen sie sind
regelmäßig gäste im tierheim
rosenwasser bezeichnet sich als
bisexuell
das heißt sie fühlt sich zu frauen und
männern hingezogen
in ihren jugendjahren war sie aber
ausschließlich mit männern zusammen
johanna
brandt
auf raue heißt in welcher weise
sexualisiert dargestellt werden danach
meint das ist normal
bezeichnet
ich finde es schön wenn frauen an drogen
sind waren die eine menge kraft
femininen sind und ich bin richtig
gemacht seien schlicht durch spezielle
unüblich dass du als frau
das hat einfach eine zu frühe ko mein
tipp gegeben
[Gelächter]
ich schließe
seit einem jahr wohnen florida und anna
zusammen in einer kleinen wohnung im
zürcher kreis 5 die beiden beschäftigt
was viele paare in ihrem alltag
beschäftigt es wird geheiratet im
freundeskreis sie selbst haben ein
zwiespältiges verhältnis zu hochzeiten
und
verpflichte gesellschaft gar nicht gut
gehe und
weiß was im bereich der wand
gesellschaft das gute gegner mit ich
sehe dass es jeden fall verschiedene
alte geht schon wieder
gut und richtig so
vorstelle ich glaube noch herzig aber
wir machen sie beziehen
also erfindet
zusammenzukommen von einem jahr
wahrscheinlich ebenso wie der größte
brocken mitgemacht und die große größen
erlaubt ist dem paar das heiraten zu
diesem zeitpunkt aber noch nicht es ist
erst ein gedankenspiel ich meine das
wäre für mich ein vertrauter damit man
die eigene playlist love
das ist super
da schon mal 8
wir haben das so also mir in der politik
etwas mehr wäre da ist meine liebste
als geschäftsführerin der
lesbenorganisation schweiz ist eine
rosenwasser zu besuch in st gallen an
der spree einer queeren
studentenorganisation an erster stelle
steht hier das gerade wichtigste thema
der community der lange kampf für die
ehe für alle
ich will gleichberechtigung ich habe es
satt zu warten und ich bin erst 30 jahre
alt und ich habe schon sorgt zu warten
ist man stelle sich mal vor wie es
unsere vorkämpferinnen sagt hatten zu
warten
ich habe auch ein bisschen geschichte
studiert und eines der wichtigsten dinge
die ich da gelernt habe ist dass
soziale bewegungen und veränderungen in
der gesellschaft nicht dadurch kamen
dass leute gefragt haben tschuldigung
kröte machte spitzley mehr gerechtigkeit
ganz pitzling bitte sondern dass leute
mega hastig waren und alles geworden
haben die komplette gleichberechtigung
und das mache ich auch
einer rosenwasser gibt sich kämpferisch
das kommt beim publikum an das netzwerk
macht außerdem trug sie vor ihrer augen
sitzen welche man sich sehr genau dem
rapper besetzt und sich sehr niedrig das
überbrachte
entspannend wie sie ihre generation
unser argument irrt oder auch adria ist
eine sache wo sie jetzt kritisiert wo
die rahmung gemacht ein neuer generation
da wenig bedeutet sparen sie mit dem bin
ich auch die trophäe
ja
ich habe es verloren gegangen von dem wo
wir hinwollen reich oder erreicht und
ich finde es mit ihrem
im gegenteil es ist wie transformiert
und weiterentwickeln und jörg sind wenn
sie dafür ihre generation weiter
verbreitete nicht da die totale grün
aufrüsten
[Musik]
von gleichgesinnten erhält anna
rosenwasser viel zuspruch aber wie sie
das außerhalb der blase aus unterwegs
mit dem jüngeren bruder den er
beobachtet die welt seiner schwester mit
kritischer distanz
also
nicht zu der bubble girl von katy perry
und alles was man sich im hause
normalität ist natalie
befremdlich wenn als dissident yang
zelebrieren als schwuler zelebrieren
oder ganz
sexualität zelebrieren und digital die
sache mit so greg chance und so und das
ist natürlich komisch für mich das ist
nämlich auch fremden da
mit dazu aber grundsätzlich
im grundsätzlich finde ich das cool das
thema ist die für verschiedene heute und
auch die effektive andere wo sich mit
sich selbst also für alle oder
vaterschaftsurlaub das
mega-event
aber wenn man wieder diskutieren dann
also potenziell heikle und ich möchte
gar nicht unbedingt ich möchte
frauen
heute diskutieren sie aber die beiden
besuchen eine ausstellung im stapferhaus
lenzburg zum thema geschlechter
identitäten
[Musik]
an der rosengasse hat die ausstellungs
machenden beraten und selber mitgewirkt
[Musik]
ja was ist denn das jetzt nur frau und
mann in islamischer so
generell grund richtige spieler ich weiß
nicht was im ihre zuhörer immer wieder
vor den kopf stoßen sich speziell halt
super
wenn wir achter
dort oder irgendwo frau extra männlich
kurzum so als
letzter über
dominikanerin ist ja
personally sich von xi aber
ja ich weiß nicht woher das kommt das
geschlecht als spielwiese die
traditionellen rollen von mann und frau
aufgeweicht für anna eine notwendigkeit
für ihren bruder eine provokation
ich glaube ich der sonst so
missverständlich ist das alte großteil
foto denn so dass gender check mit dem
missverständnis
aber es wird
überschätzt
sei
etwas das ich gerne habe
und ich finde es schön ich für die
heizung sage
es gibt einfach mega für formen von frau
sie
eine diskussion die noch nicht zu ende
ist aber zumindest für einen nachmittag
scheinen auch die rollen zwischen bruder
und schwester nicht mehr ganz so klar
verteilt
und das ist mit
dem typisch broadcast
mit anna rosenwasser wachsender
bekanntheit hat auch die
arbeitsbelastung zugenommen das hat
einen preis
vor wenigen tagen hat sie eine
entscheidung getroffen
guten morgen liebe steam ich schreibe
euch dieses mail um euch zu erzählen
dass auch ich meinte loos abgeben werde
nun ja genau genommen ist das timing
meiner erschöpfung geschuldet ging es
nach überzeugung und freude würde ich
noch jahrelang weiter los bleiben
ja ich kann deine halbjahr bin ich immer
wieder info
des stresses masako hat mich um mich
mega fester termin zu bringt und ich
weiß dass mega normal gilt das gilt als
mega nochmals um bis zu dämpfen
aber ich bin nie verstanden neben der
festanstellung bei der
lesbenorganisation
arbeitet anna als kolumnistin und
autorin
mitschreiben und auftritten will sie
sich von nun an den lebensunterhalt
verdienen ein sprung ins ungewisse
ich weiß ja nicht wie es mit der
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit am in ihrer
tätigkeit um ihre person wieder gehabt
das hat die reale zu entwicklungsplan
das hat eine eigendynamik nicht nur
begrenzt frauen stören das heißt es kann
als sie das innerhalb von
barroso
und dann wird vermutlich ab
[Musik]
nur noch selten ist anna rosenwasser zu
besuch in der heimat in flurlingen hier
im zürcher weinland ist sie aufgewachsen
noch immer treffen sich ihre verwandten
hier jeden samstag zum mittagessen die
familie verfolgt annas aktivismus genau
was ich bin immer
negativ
fertige geht
das stört mich erhöht was wird dann also
was kirsten negativ
war einfach ein anderem einige antworten
findet sie
aber
ja das könnte ich meinen das ist extrem
dünn das braucht extrem ohne extrem
geht's komitee richtig
dass das extreme 40 die fließt
erschaffen ist
sozialpolitisch und das meint das 104
ungefähr
wer nur die woche ist er heiß diskutiert
wird und das trumm mit der vollen summe
präsent sie das
thema
ist die bedrohung ausgesetzt morgen ist
erste klasse hat
kritische nachricht wohl irgendein heinz
zum inneren auge und ist das erste 7 und
ich ließ
japan mindestens zwei wird nun nötigen
wird es oberflächlich betrachtet
diskussionen zum inhalt mehr wie
oberflächlich heben einige irgendwie
stark
us-wahlkampf endlichkeit danke vielfach
ich glaube empfindlich sie ist gar nicht
schlecht das heißt dass man verletzlich
ist ich möchte mir eigentlich nicht er
hat die mut zur tour will es auf der
welt gibt mir kraft wand zur
gestand interview das ich habe zwei
wanduhr guineer acht vorträge oder wann
du einfach
produkt wie ich fühle dass sie eine
produkt vielleicht ist er verletzt war
draxler hinterherläuft dann ist aber
diskussion eigentlich an und fühlte sich
verletzt sondern ich bin's
ist diese neue generation der
aktivistinnen empfindlich regt sie sich
zu sehr über kleinigkeiten auf oder ist
sie verletzlicher als das selbstbewusste
auftreten vermuten lässt
hier in flurlingen ist anna aufgewachsen
hier können sie auch mal eine andere
sein als in der öffentlichkeit
vertritt und sich selbst
was ich sehr krank ich muss sie ist sie
halte es für bisschen kuscheln
ja wohl viel wie hey und machen sie sich
aussage wenn er sich
der öffentlichkeit uns sitzt
also sorge solange das spiel
im griff oder manche und dumme wurde
dass mit ihr
kommuniziert dann mache ich mir keine
sorgen dass sie sich dank sich noch
brutal und
ihre e mails und internet
rück mal die gelbe tonne mit willis
deren masse
bekannte
hits
motto ja das will ich nicht wähle
anna rosenwasser ist hier zusammen mit
ihren drei jüngeren brüdern mutter und
vater aufgewachsen die eltern haben sich
getrennt als sie ein teenager war über
den vater will anna in diesem film nicht
reden aber er hat sie geprägt auch durch
seine jüdische zugehörigkeit
hebräisch lernen programm ich glaub
mische wurzel handel zur betreibt das
ich gelernt haben dass meine küche zur
kirche sich nicht ausgesucht
und sie haben mir beigebracht
reformen für diskriminierungen wir
funktionieren
dort bald als person wo offizielle
jüdisch aber als person wo immer für
jüdisch kälter wird und das bringt mir
sehr viel
seit einer kündigung ist sie in den
medien präsenter denn je zu allen
möglichen themen
herzlich willkommen im literaturclub
sind viel militanter geworden gegenüber
der politik und korrekt mesmer
dabei kommt sie unterschiedlich an
charmant und konstruktiv sagen die einen
vor laut und aggressiv die anderen die
zahl der followers wächst weiter
gerade mit ihrem instagram auftritt
polarisiert und provoziert anna
rosenwasser mit absicht
also ich kommuniziere in imst und ich
verstehe das als provokant wagner wird
und ich bin durchaus hastig und dann
gucke mir hasse kurs und auch das wird
aus provokation
das rezept scheint aufzugehen bereits
verdient sie auf instagram mit bezahlter
werbung geld und eine agentur hat
angeklopft die sie managen will die
größere reichweite hat allerdings auch
schattenseiten auch die zahl der hass
nachrichten steigt
mit wechsel irgendwann jährige fremde
das ist so hässlich dass mich eine
zweite welle natürlich notgeile aus
aber was macht das mit einer sozia es
war schwierig zu sagen
dass ich eines ist ein ekel und sicheres
und wo sie das lied ein so scheiße
findet das schreiben
einer rosenwasser arbeit bei der
lesbenorganisation neigt sich dem ende
zu im büro in bern übergibt sie ihre
aufgaben an eine ihrer nachfolgerinnen
aber herrscht noch irgendwas ist anders
whatsup newsletter
rund vier jahre lang war anna bei der
lesbenorganisation loos was hat sie
bewirkt nur schwer neue öffentlichkeit
für viele jahre junge leisten für junge
bis so eine landschaft und das hat das
haus zu sehr viel voraus in der letzten
jahre
dass anna rosenwasser zu einem vorbild
für junge frauen geworden ist zeigt sich
auch an ihren sogenannten treffpunkten
anna hat diese treffpunkte ins leben
gerufen die idee junge menschen
versammeln sich als gruppe und gehen
gemeinsam an eine queere party
erzählt ob jetzt mit mir offiziell
unterwegs das heißt man royal 100 oder
gern begleitet zum kurz berühren stelle
moment oder so im raum janka nerven ok
wichtige regler iren haben mit mir da
nicht einfach zu mir und dann gehöre
dazu mir falls das bedürfnis ist für
[Applaus]
die gruppe soll sicherheit geben zum
beispiel denen die neu sind in der
community es kommen junge menschen aus
der ganzen schweiz heute zu einer party
in der roten fabrik in zürich
wenn es halb so viel wie jetzt
was ist mit wüste 2 mio wie lego und
deswegen muss so hätten forscher vor zu
kennen lerne ich ganz sicher
wir sind ein treffpunkt wo will mehr als
pitts einzelgänger sind und wir haben
auch gewiss tanner gehen das heißt die
sicherheit und laut ist nie allein die
folge dann noch nicht so lange bereich
sich die erfolge ist den recht ergangen
wie sie begleitet haben und dass es ist
version wegbegleiterin einfach
inspirieren sich ja auf jeden fall ist
sie hätten die schöne sie dem ruf zeigt
will wenn man wenn man merkt mal ich
nicht hätte roten
ford kuga und den findet man schnell man
noch schlechter und der kunde an
ich finde ich mega berührt
dann wird und energie geht's zum video
machen
versuche eigentlich die person sieht
mich auch gerne hätte früheren und ich
finde es immer mega berührend wenn sie
bis druck gibt das ist magisch sogar
schafft
es ist nicht nur das
zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl das den
jungen menschen hilft es ist auch die
stärke einer gruppe die schutz bietet
vor übergriffen
es ist so wenige serial sei als
kriterium wächst
und wächst und dass man vielleicht
einmal gemacht wird
geschätzt dass
ich
ständig an die eigene sicherheit denken
wird ihre menschen immer noch eine
realität
[Musik]
das große engagement ziert analysen
wassers kräften sich selber sorge tragen
wird deshalb immer mehr zum thema in
letzter zeit hat sie mehrmals
einladungen ausgeschlagen zu
streitgesprächen mit gegnern der ehe für
alle gelegenheiten die sie früher
wahrgenommen hat lässt sie nun auch mal
verstreichen
ich habe die letzten monate
lernen dass ich nicht zu jeder
gelegenheit muss ja sagen sondern das
nein danke sagte alex und franz setze
ich kann nicht alle anderen bis kurz vor
und mehr
aber kann das politische aktivistin ist
man ja an bremen einige haushalte nur
die eigene blase blieben wo man nur
bestätigen ich glaube ich kann mich auch
mit kritischen stimmen auseinander
setzen ohne dass ich es muss halt in dem
moment wo ich mir für meine politischen
sagen dass ich kein recht verdienen kann
macht das mit mir und es ist wichtig
dass sich sorgsam in energie umgangen
es ist abstimmungssonntag ein tag der
auch persönlich etwas für anna
rosenwasser verändert
aber erstmal ihre beziehung
und doch so schön die freiheit vor ein
freudentag und trotzdem ist eine
rosenwasser froh dass der
abstimmungskampf nun vorbei ist
das fand ich nicht die ganze zeit was
sie die ganze zeit traurig dass man
meistens mache community arbeit in der
kabarett arbeit
ich sehe jeden tag was es bringt und
dass es sinn macht und das ist wichtiger
als alles andere
weiter kämpfen aber mit fokus auf die
community
sie ist es diana rosenwasser kraft gibt
und die motivation weiterzumachen
denn die arbeit ist für sie längst nicht
zu ende
[Musik]